what's going on everybody welcome back
to another video today we're gonna be
talking about how to become a data
analyst without any experience
[Music]
now when i say no experience that can
mean a few different things you could be
right out of college and so you've just
never gotten a job so of course you
don't have any experience or you could
be somebody who's trying to switch
careers like you were an accountant or a
therapist or a teacher and you're trying
to become a data analyst now speaking
for myself i switch careers i used to be
working at a behavioral health hospital
where i led group therapies i have a
degree in recreational therapy so as you
can tell i made a pretty big career
change and i have an entire video
dedicated to talking about that entire
process of how i was able to switch
careers and so i'll leave a link right
up here in case you want to watch that
but everything that we're going to talk
about today are things that i actually
did in order to become a data analyst
and i had absolutely no experience at
all in fact six months before i got my
first data analyst job i did not know
what a data analyst was i mean i was
really really new at this and i was kind
of piecing everything together and so if
you are trying to become a data analyst
and you have no experience and you are
trying to piece it all together to
figure out how to make that happen this
video is for you and so we're going to
walk through this process from the very
beginning to the very ends and i'm going
to give you my best advice as well as
some tips and tricks that i learned
along the way when i was trying to get
my first job when i had no experience
without further ado let's jump into it
and like i said i'ma start from the very
beginning and so you need to have the
right skills that a data analyst has the
ones that i recommend focusing on the
most especially when you're first
starting out are sql and then you need a
bi tool like tableau or power bi and
then excel and then lastly python i
would learn those skills in that order
and there are so many places that you
can learn these things two places that i
recommend are udemy and coursera i've
made videos for both of those platforms
talking about courses that i have taken
and i recommend and of course both of
those videos focus on these skills that
we were just talking about of sql
tableau power bi excel and python now
the very next step in this process is to
build a portfolio project now i was not
smart enough to actually do this i just
sent scripts along with my resume and it
worked but if i had a portfolio i'm
telling you it would have made a huge
difference a portfolio project is a way
for you to demonstrate your skills to a
potential employer and so if you're
learning sql or python or tableau or
power bi and you make a portfolio
project you can then show that to the
employer and they can see your skill
level in that area the goal of this is
to create three to five projects that
you can put together either on a website
or in github then you can put that on
your linkedin or your resume so that if
a potential employer is looking at you
to potentially hire you they can see
your skill level and feel a lot more
confident in hiring you as of right now
we're walking through a data analyst
portfolio project series on my channel
and so if you want some ideas on
projects and you actually want to be
guided through and walk through every
single step of the way then be sure to
check those out now you don't have any
data analyst experience at all so your
last job might be something like a
cashier or a teacher or a consultant or
something completely random that has
nothing to do with data analysis my
biggest tip by far is to put everything
that is data analyst related at the top
the last thing that you want to do when
you have no experience is to put your
work history at the top because a
potential employer or a hiring manager
is going to look at your resume and see
that your last job was a cashier or a
teacher and they're going to say well
this guy doesn't have any experience i'm
not going to hire him and they throw
your resume away but if the first thing
that they see on your resume is your
skills section and it says sql power bi
tableau excel and python they might just
move on to the next section which would
then be your portfolio project section
and they see everything from data
exploration data cleaning data
visualization and at that point
hopefully they'll click on the link that
will bring them to your portfolio
website and they can see all of your
projects and they can see the skill
level that you have and all these skills
that they actually want and then at that
point when they get to your job history
and they see that you have no experience
they may just give you a shot because
you have all the skills that they're
looking for now of course that's not
going to happen with every job that you
apply for but that is the general idea
of formatting in that way again i have
created an entire video dedicated to
creating a data analyst resume so i will
leave a link here as well as down there
if you want to check that out now
everything that we just talked about is
preparing you to apply for jobs and so
we are at the part of the process we are
going to start applying for jobs and i
think the very first thing that we need
to look at is linkedin linkedin has by
far been the best place to look for jobs
especially when i was starting out with
no experience and so the very first
thing that i would do is optimize your
linkedin profile be sure to add your
resume to your profile also add your
personal projects you've created and
your portfolio so that people can check
those out and then at the very bottom in
the skill section be sure to add every
single skill that you know that is
related to data analytics one other
thing that i would recommend that you do
to your profile is at the very top where
it says show recruiters you're open to
work that you click on that and add all
the job titles and the locations that
you're looking for jobs now after you've
updated your profile you are ready to
start reaching out to recruiters and
that is the very next step now i say
reach out to recruiters but with the
linkedin profile that we just set up
there's a good chance that you'll have
people reach out to you who are
recruiting for data analyst positions
and if so that is the best case scenario
because you did little to no work and
they're reaching out to you for you to
get an interview now why would you want
to work with a recruiter when you can
just apply for jobs yourself well to be
honest there are so many reasons uh but
one of the biggest ones is that a
recruiter is literally there to help you
find a job i mean they get paid for
placing people in jobs and so when you
have no experience and you're just
applying on glassdoor or a zip recruiter
a lot of times your resume is getting
filtered out because you don't have any
experience whereas when you're working
with a recruiter you can talk them
through where you're currently at and
then they can help you find a job that
is best suited to your current skill
level that's how i landed my first data
analyst job and that's how i also landed
every single other data analyst job i've
had since so how do you actually start
working with a recruiter you can do it
in one of two ways you can reach out to
them or they can reach out to you when
we were talking about our linkedin
profile earlier we have that show
recruiters you're open to work and you
put some job descriptions in there that
is a way that recruiters can find you
and then reach out to you for a
potential job the other way to do it is
to reach out to recruiters and so you
can also do this on linkedin if you find
a job that you like in the job section
you can click on the company you can
actually search for recruiters who work
at that company and message them
directly the other way to do it is just
to go on google and search for local
recruiters and you can give them a call
or you can send them an email with your
resume and then hopefully they will call
you back or email you back and that's
how you get in touch after you work with
them a while hopefully you're starting
to get interviews and you really need to
prep for interviews as well as the
technical interview the technical
interview is a portion of the interview
where they want to test your technical
abilities to make sure that your skill
level is good enough for what they are
wanting after you nail your interview
hopefully you get a job offer and you
get your first job as a data analyst and
congratulations because that is a huge
accomplishment and after you land that
first data analyst job it makes it 10
times easier to get your next one i
highly recommend going back and checking
out a lot of the videos that we talked
about in this video they go a lot more
in depth into the topics that we
discussed and hopefully it'll give you a
much better picture of what you should
be doing so to everyone who is still
watching who's trying to become a data
analyst i wish you the best of luck and
i know you can do it and i know that it
is hard work but it will absolutely be
worth it thank you guys so much for
watching i really appreciate it if you
like this video be sure to like and
subscribe below and i'll see you in the
next video
[Music]
you